DEMARNDS
DEMANDING RELEASE OF THE MAYOR
AND ZELENSKYY HAD THE FRENCH
PRESIDENT ASK PUTIN ABOUT THE
KIDNAPPING DURING A PHONE CALL
YESTERDAY.
JOINING ME TO TALK ABOUT THIS,
KGB AGENT MARXKY AUTHOR OF "DEEP
UNDERCOVER."
HE'S ALSO THE EXECUTIVE PRODUCER
OF THE AGENT STREAMING ON MAJOR
PLAID FORMS.
JACK, THANKS FOR JOINING US.
YOU KNOW, PUTIN IS FACING
WORLDWIDE SCRUTINY FOR THIS
UNPROVOKED WAR.
DO YOU THINK HE'S STILL, THE KGB
AGENT HE WAS SO MANY YEARS AGO?
RELYING ON THAT TRAINING,
RELYING ON THOSE MIND GAMES THAT
KGB AGENTS PLAY AT THIS VERY
MOMENT?
>> I HAVE TO DISABUSE YOU OF THE
NOTION THAT THE MAN HE IS TODAY
WAS TRAINED BY THE KGB.
HE GOT HIS POLITICAL SKILLS AND
WHATEVER HE USES FROM THE KGB.
HE WAS A MID-LEVEL BUREAUCRAT IN
THE KGB.
HE SERVED IN THE CITY OF DRESDEN
IN THE '80s, AND I HAPPEN TO
HAVE MET AN EX-BOSS OF HIS.
OLICK KALUGAN, IN CHARGE OF
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE OF THE KGB,
WHICH WAS ESPIONAGE AND HE WILL
TELL YOU HE WAS NOT IMPRESSED
WITH MR. PUTIN.
PUTIN IS A PHENOMENAL
POLITICIAN, AND A MASTER CHESS
PLAYER, BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, HE
HAS BEEN IN POWER FOR THE LAST
22 YEARS, IN A COUNTRY WHERE THE
STANDARD OF LIVING HASN'T MUCH
GREW.
PARTICULARLY OUTSIDE OF THE BIG
CITIES.
SO -- HOW HE GOT TO WHO HE IS
TODAY IS PROBABLY NOT THAT
RELEVANT, BUT LET'S NOT THINK
THAT KGB AGENTS ARE SUPERMEN.
I AM NOT AND I WAS ONE OF THE
BEST TRAINED AGENTS EVER SENT
OUT.
>> THAT LEADS ME TO MY NEXT
QUESTION, WHICH IS, PUTIN IS NOT
INVINCIBLE.
YOU KNOW, WE SPOKE WITH THE
FORMER CIA CHIEF OF RUSSIA
OPERATIONS YESTERDAY AND HE TOLD
ME PUTIN FEARS NOT THE OLIGARCHS
OR RUSSIAN PEOPLE TURNING ON
HIM.
IT'S HIS FELLOW SPIES.
PEOPLE IN HIS NATIONAL SECURITY
REALM AROUND HIM.
>> YES.
>> INTELLIGENCE PEOPLE AROUND
HIM.
>> YES.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> AND THAT WAS DAN HOFFMAN, I
BELIEVE.
>> STEVE HALL MADE THAT
OBSERVATION BUT OTHERS --
>> OH, BEN HOFFMAN ALSO HEAD OF
CIA AND I HEARD HIM.
HE SAYS THE SAME THING.
THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
PUTIN HAS A COMPLETE DISREGARD
OF WHAT HIS, HIS PEOPLE ARE
THINKING AND DOING.
HE KNOWS THAT HE CAN KEEP THEM
UNDER CONTROL AS LONG AS HE ALSO
HAS THE POWER PLAYERS IN HIS
REGIME UNDER CONTROL, BECAUSE IF
HE DOESN'T, YOU KNOW, HE'S
TOAST.
THERE WILL BE A PALACE REVOLT
AND HE'S DONE.
AND HE -- HE HAS TO REALLY WALK
A FINE LINE, BECAUSE HE PUT
HIMSELF INTO A SITUATION NOW
THAT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR HIM
TO GET OUT OF.
IF HE THINKS HE CAN OCCUPY
UKRAINE AND DECLARE VICTORY, HE
IS WRONG, BECAUSE I'VE HEARD
OTHER PEOPLE SAY WHAT I SAID
RIGHT WHEN THIS THING STARTED,
UKRAINE WILL BE DEFEATED.
YOU CANNOT, YOU CANNOT DEFEAT A
COUNTRY WHEN YOU FIGHT THE
ENTIRE POPULATION.
LOST VIETNAM, LOST AFGHANISTAN,
SOVIETS LOST AFGHANISTAN.
THIS WOULD BE A VERY PROLONGED,
VERY BLOODY PARTISAN KIND OF
FIGHT WHERE TOO MANY, YOU KNOW,
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WOULD BE KILLED
AND COME HOME AND EVENTUALLY
PUTIN'S LEGACY WOULD BE CAPUT
AND HE WOULD BE DEPOSED.
THE CHOICE HE MAY HAVE STILL IS
FIND THIS OFF RAMP WHERE HE CAN
DECLARE VICTORY, GET OUT, AND
GET CONCESSIONS FROM THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT, BUT THAT'S
NOT ENTIRELY DEPENDENT ON HIM.
HE PUT HIMSELF INTO A REALLY
TIGHT SITUATION.
>> AND, YOU KNOW, THERE HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
HIS MIND-SET.
ISOLATED BECAUSE OF COVID.
AT LEAST THAT'S THE REPORTING
THAT COMES OUT ABOUT HOW PUTIN
HAS BEEN BEHAVING DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
YOU SEE BIZARRE PHOTO OPS, LONG
TABLES, DOZENS OF FEET AWAY FROM
ANYBODY.
I'VE DESCRIBED IT AS PUTIN IN
WONDERLAND.
I MEAN WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
HIS MIND-SET AT THIS POINT?
IS HE LIVING IN SORT OF AN
UPSIDE-DOWN WORLD?
A REALITY OF HIS OWN MAKING?
>> WELL, A DICTATOR LIKE
VLADIMIR PUTIN OR ADOLF
HITLER -- NOT SAYING THEY'RE THE
SAME -- BUT ANYTHING WHO IS
COMPLETELY IN CHARGE OF A WHOLE
COUNTRY MUST TOTALLY BELIEVE IN
HIMSELF.
ALL RIGHT?
AND YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE BEEN
OTHER BIZARRE PHOTOS IN THE
HISTORY OF PUTIN AS A PRESIDENT,
HALF NAKED PICTURE ON A HORSE,
OR WHEN HE PLAYS ICE HOCKEY
AGAINST SOVIET NATIONAL TEAM.
ALL OF THIS INDICATES THAT HE,
HE HAS NO -- HE HAS NO -- LITTLE
MAN IN HIS HEAD THAT CHECKS ON
HIM OCCASIONALLY.
SO -- HE BELIEVES IN HIMSELF,
PERIOD, AND IF YOU THINK, AND
I'VE MET PEOPLE LIKE THAT IN
CORPORATE AMERICA.
IF YOU THINK YOU'RE ALWAYS THE
SMARTEST PERSON IN THE ROOM, YOU
SET YOURSELF UP FOR FAILURE.
I THINK HE IS AT THAT POINT.
HE MAY WELL HAVE DISREGARDED
INTELLIGENCE AND NOW BLAMING A
COUPLE OF GUYS FROM THE FSB FOR
BAD INTELLIGENCE.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
I DON'T -- I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THEY DIDN'T KNOW HOW UKRAINE AND
THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE WOULD ACT.
HE PROBABLY IGNORED IT, BECAUSE